the jurgen experience
so speaking of we're humans like tell me
about this lyme disease thing man
because i'm terrified of lyme disease
yeah it's a [ __ ] um
so i uh like 2015
uh
i started feeling like [ __ ] you know and
it was like joint pain
i was getting some uh like neuropathy i
i'd sit on the floor with my kids and my
legs would fall asleep or you know like
just positional [ __ ] and it's like i
[ __ ] my neck up in 2014 uh like 10
days before i fought yancey maderos um
so i was like okay my next banged up
like like bulging disc like um i don't
even really know did you get an mri no i
didn't get an mri it was ten days before
the fight uh it was the most
unspectacular thing it was like a
whiplash injury uh
i uh i was sparring uh mickey golf when
he was like 22 21 and uh he threw like a
hook and i just clinched a body lock and
my head hit his his chest and it just
tweaked to my left and like i felt it i
have it on video and it's like
i like shrugged my shoulders move my
head around it was the last round of the
day i was like all right this is gonna
hurt later but we're gonna get through
it um like i only got to that fight
because of you know a chiropractor and
his magic fingers uh and some graston uh
but uh
so like
a lot of the symptoms that i was getting
um
from the lime i attribute it to being a
fighter like my knees hurt of course
they [ __ ] hurt like
uh you know i mean to the point where
i'd be 45 minutes into a training
session and have to get up like an old
man push on my knees and stuff like that
it's getting you know numbness and
tingling uh i was getting
like brain fog
and
it was pretty good i kind of like go
into a room sometimes and like go to
like clean up
and just kind of get lost
um
so uh
before my fight at 196 um
like it got so bad that i was like i was
contemplating retirement at ufc 200 i
was like i'm going to get through 196
i'm going to ask to fight on 200 to
retire
um
and uh you did not know you had long did
not know i had lyme disease um you know
like i said i
nervous system was was kind of shot
um
joints were swollen i'd get some
twitching in my eye was mostly where i'd
get it just for like days on end
um
very occasionally i would
say the wrong word while i was speaking
and not even anything close like just
the complete wrong word would come out
um
and you know you'd notice and you're
like what the [ __ ] did i just say i hope
they didn't notice um
so i was telling my doctor about this uh
before my pre-fight physical uh
or during my pre-flight physical for 196
and he's like you know he's like
honestly i i think you have lyme disease
and i was like all right you know so we
we ran some tests tested me for lyme um
to this day i still don't test positive
it's about 50 of the people
uh on that have lyme test positive for
it
um
so he's like
uh if it's lyme disease you know and
he's like we ran some other tests
there's some antibody that i had that
showed an infection
that they associate sometimes with lyme
um
so he's like we're gonna put you on doxy
and he's like if if you do have lyme
disease within you know a week ten days
he's like you're gonna feel different
you know what is it called doxing doxa
cycling dog's recycling um
so like i fight
uh
fight diego and that was the first time
like i was i was kind of out of it i
barely trained for that fight um like
i would i would
miss training sessions like live
grappling sessions or sparring sessions
and
like because i could barely get out of
bed or like uh so i was i i would i
would get in maybe six sessions a week
um you know and kind of just focused on
like all right well just be in shape you
know like i could run on the treadmill
it's
the easiest thing for me to do at that
point was to run on the treadmill which
is weird it's different than what most
people experience most people experience
uh
difficulty doing aerobic exercise and
uh
they can do anaerobic stuff i couldn't
do anaerobic stuff like if i lifted
uh
or did sprints i'd be banged up for
[ __ ] days
um
so
and and that fight like
i remember like when i when i fight
and i think it it has to do something
with the lights too like i don't see the
cage like beyond the cage i don't see
anybody in the stands
i don't
i barely hear my [ __ ] corner for
crying out loud um
so
that fight i the whole during the whole
fight i could see like throughout in the
stands you know i was so like unfocused
um
that like it was just it was a weird
experience it's the only time it's ever
happened to me
um
but i get out of the fight uh
and uh and get on some doc cycling uh
the following week and it was like
within
a week or so just like my doctor said i
started feeling way [ __ ] better
um
it took me a few years to figure out
when exactly i got bit i had assumed
that it was probably early 2015 and then
after learning about uh
you know the early symptoms of lyme
disease and pulling my head out of my
ass and remembering the experience that
i had in 2013
it i'm i'm
pretty much 100 confident that i was
bitten like
late may early june of 2013. what makes
you think though uh i had a period of
time where i was like i basically had
morning sickness i was extremely
nauseous in the morning um
and and like early lime it's like
flu-like symptoms and and and migraines
and stuff like that and so i had really
bad nausea like if i picked up my coffee
cup and i was like breathing in and i
got a big whiff of my coffee it would
make me gag
really yeah uh like brushing my teeth
i'd [ __ ] just take the taste of like
the toothpaste make me gag uh i had two
kids in diapers at the time every time
bringing the friggin garbage out oh man
i'd be dry heaving the whole way down
the down the driveway for like two weeks
and i was like my kids are in daycare i
think my my niece had like rotovirus or
something at the time i was like i got a
stomach bug like whatever
um and then i got a series of migraines
like right kind of as the the nausea was
dying down i got i don't know i think it
was like seven migraines in 10 days or
something like that
so
i went to uh neurologist in ent ran a
bunch of tests they tested me for lyme
tested negative
uh they couldn't find anything so
they're like hey let's just we're gonna
we're gonna kick the ball down the road
a little bit see if it comes back and
you know uh and and figure out what we
can do
um
so that i kind of forgot about that um
and uh
after you know kind of educating myself
online after i
uh
you know was diagnosed uh i was like
maybe you know maybe that's when it was
um but it took a it took a while to get
over because it was
you know just about three years that it
had
untreated
uh you know and and the bacteria is a
sneaky little [ __ ] uh they call it the
great imitator because it can give
everybody completely different symptoms
um
and it can pass the blood brain barrier
and and this all this other [ __ ] you
know um
it also has a uh
like a toxin in the cell wall of it so
if you kill too much of it at one time
uh or in a short period of time you
experience what's called like the
herxheimer reaction uh which is
basically you're being like poisoned by
the death of the lyme bacteria
yeah it's a it's a shitty it makes it it
makes you it's it's a [ __ ] amazing
thing because it's like here's this
little thing that this little bacteria
that when it dies it makes you
change what you're doing
so that you don't like it's a getting
over lyme is especially like
like untreated for a while is a marathon
and i'm not good at that [ __ ] um
so like i i was on doc cycling for six
months um you know i i've ended up six
months yeah and it's uh that's an
antibiotic yeah it's an antibiotic i was
i was i was i was [ __ ] [ __ ]
like four to five times before noon i
mean in in 2016 so
leading up to
like i started to lose a little weight
in 2015 but uh i used to walk
just under a buck 90. um
after that first six months on doc's
cycling i was walking around at 163
pounds uh before the tiago alphas fight
whoa
yeah i lost a [ __ ] ton of muscle and of
course it's like oh it's usada
jim's off the sauce and i was like no
i'm pooping so much like you have no
idea
uh
that i just can't keep up with it but um
but you were still fighting i was still
fighting yeah that's crazy so but that's
not we're not even done joe
so uh i was on it for six months and uh
i felt way better
you know that was whatever it was uh
september um
then i did you know in in march so i was
like hey doc like do you think we can
you know get off of
the antibiotics and he's like yeah let's
give it a try
and it was about seven weeks and then i
started to feel like my symptoms were
coming back
um and then me being an [ __ ] and like
no no they're not like it's it's not
it's not the lime again
so like i kind of waited
and
by the end of the year uh it [ __ ]
kicked my ass um
like leading up into uh
what was that 208
uh
when i fought dustin like that was
that was the hardest couple weeks before
a fight that i've i've ever had like i i
because i was trying to get back on the
doxycycline i was trying to to
supplement even way better and you know
you're not supposed to take it within
two hours like two hours before two
hours after supplements and stuff like
that and
like i don't like working out with food
in my stomach so
and i can't take the doxy on an empty
stomach because it then you know
makes my stomach upset so
uh so i was like trying to figure out
like the best way to get back on it and
it just kept kicking my butt and kicking
my butt um
finally like
i don't know maybe two weeks before the
fight i started to kind of get it get it
dialed in uh and then unfortunately i
was
like fight week i was uh i was having a
herx uh reaction and uh
it was a really weird experience
getting uh
i was i was having like muscle tremors
when i was cutting weight so like i was
sitting there
like punching yeah yeah i couldn't stop
couldn't stop my arms from moving uh
like it's gonna be freaky my my vision
was a little messed up and i don't know
if it was the lights or whatever but
like when i fought dustin that night
like every to me like everything kind of
had like a
yellow hue to it it was weird
um and i don't know if that was just my
eyes being weird or what but so this is
the side effect of the virus exuding a
poison yeah yeah yeah cause i i finally
like kind of figured it out uh like
right right before that fight
um
so then
like 2017 was uh like i was still
dealing with it
and
it it was it was difficult like the
first half of the year was pretty
difficult
um and then like
through the through the summer um
it started to like get a lot better for
me
uh
you know i changed my diet i started
eating a lot like a lot better food i
mean like when i first found out i had
lime like we were trying to like
kind of adhere to the lime diet you know
the lime lime diet is like basically a
paleo it's a it's an inflammatory
disease so avoiding alcohol sugar
gluten uh dairy stuff like that but it's
like i also had a bunch of little kids
and it's like well if i'm making my food
and trying to make their food so they're
not eating mac and cheese hot dogs and
chicken fingers every day
like this is going to be really [ __ ]
hard so
you know like i've never like
adhered to that diet like specifically
but
totally eat a ton more like whole foods
and vegetables and [ __ ] like that now so
uh and definitely like
i eat way or drink way less you know so
how did you get off of how did you kill
the lime is it 100 done or do you still
have like relapses i haven't had a
relapse uh
since
yeah about about
2017 yeah oh that's nice so five [ __ ]
years yeah freedom yeah um so you went
through it for a sense essentially like
a solid four years a few years yeah so
it was uh
well like it it took a while for it to
start kicking my butt you know like i
had that first instance in 2013 when it
was when i first got bit
but then like i couldn't really tell
anything you know but if you had gotten
on antibiotics right then you probably
could just get killed yeah yeah three to
three to four weeks uh is usually um
what doctors will uh
you know prescribe uh and if you catch
it early
you usually
fare pretty well with it um
um
but like yeah it was uh
i mean 2017
i didn't feel like i could start really
like
excuse me uh like pushing myself and and
sprinting and lifting again until like
maybe april of 2018.